bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle vidéo dans laquelle je vais
vous parler du développement personnel
donc préparez vous un petit café un thé
installez vous confortablement on va
prendre le temps d'expliquer les choses
tranquillement et on se retrouve tout de
suite après le générique c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors le développement personnel c'est
un sujet très vaste très compliqué sur
lequel il faut bien le dire on entend un
petit peu tout et n'importe quoi et
notamment par des personnes qui ne
connaissent pas vraiment le sujet c'est
à dire qu'ils n'ont pas expérimenté donc
pour avoir étudié et expérimenté le
développement personnel je pense avoir
une légitimité à en parler et je vais
donc vous livrer mon point de vue dans
cette vidéo un point de vue qui n'est
que mon point de vue qui ne qui ne se
veut pas une vérité objective
ça va être simplement une analyse
personnelle de ce phénomène parce que je
pense que le développement personnel
doit d'abord être vu comme un phénomène
il doit être interprétée comme telle
avant de voir ce qu'il peut avoir du
thil ou pas dans telle ou telle
circonstance
alors qu'est ce que le développement
personnel on pourrait dire que c'est un
ensemble de méthodes un ensemble de
techniques d'aproz qui permettent une
amélioration et une transformation de
soi on pourrait dire également qui
permettent une exploitation au plus haut
niveau de son potentiel
donc vous voyez que rien que cette
définition elle est déjà en soi
problématique parce que lorsqu'on parle
d'améliorations de soi lorsqu'on parle
de réaliser son potentiel
on ne sait pas exactement dans quel
domaine on parle justement le
développement personnel s'applique à
tous les domaines
on peut l'utiliser dans le domaine
professionnel pour pour atteindre des
objectifs professionnels mais également
dans le domaine plus personnel justement
par exemple sentimentale amical social
on peut utiliser le développement
personnel par exemple pour vaincre sa
timidité pour être plus audacieux dans
nos rapports aux autres également pour
lever certains blocages certains
blocages mentaux qui nous empêche de
réaliser nos projets qui nous empêchent
d'atteindre nos objectifs
alors j'aimerais d'abord parler du
développement personnel comme d'un
symptôme un symptôme de notre de notre
époque puisque c'est un phénomène qui
est en réalité assez récent
lorsqu'on lorsqu'on étudie on s'aperçoit
que le développement personnel a été
formalisé à partir du 20e siècle avec
des ramifications dans la psychologie du
19e siècle mais ça reste un phénomène
assez moderne et assez récent et donc
pour bien comprendre ce phénomène il
faut le remettre en perspective
il faut le réinscrire dans un contexte
qui va nous permettre d'en comprendre la
signification alors il y à il ya
quelques jours j'ai fait un entretien
avec le coach en développement personnel
dans laquelle je lui faisais remarquer
que le développement personnel ne peut
naître que dans une société où la
problématique de la survie a été résolu
a été réglé le développement personnel
finalement c'est un petit peu un
privilège c'est à dire qu'on peut se
poser la question de l'amélioration de
soi quand on n'a plus à se poser la
question de comment on va se nourrir ou
comment on va s'abriter pour pouvoir
survivre
donc c'est déjà quelque chose qui
correspond à une situation sociologique
de privilégier et je pense que c'est
important de le préciser et de l'assumer
de ne pas faire comme si ce n'était pas
vrai ce sont logiquement on entre dans
le développement personnel
quand en fait on n'a pas d'autre
problème lorsqu'on est dans les
tranchées pendant la guerre lorsqu'on
doit se lever à 5 heures du matin pour
aller cultiver son champ
le développement personnel et quelque
chose de très secondaire pour ne pas
dire absurde ça n'a pas de sens de se
poser la question de comment s'améliorer
2 comment avoir une meilleure
connaissance de soi par exemple lorsque
eh bien on est confronté à la dureté de
la vie à la dureté de la réalité
maintenant une fois qu'on a dit ça il
faut aller plus loin c'est à dire qu'il
ne s'agit pas simplement de se moquer
des personnes qui ont recours au
développement personnel en disant ces
personnes là n'ont aucun problème dans
leur vie et du coup ça mérite simplement
notre métriques
non je pense que ça dit quelque chose de
beaucoup plus profond sur le besoin
le besoin qu'a tout humain tout être
humain
que sa vie ait du sens tout simplement
je pense qu'on peut pas reprocher à un
être humain de rechercher du sens de
vouloir que sa vie est un sens et qu'en
ce sens n'apparaît pas de manière
explicite de manière directe bien ce
sens on va aller le rechercher
et on va notamment leur chercher à
l'intérieur de soi et ses larmes aux
navy qu'à part et la légitimité du
développement personnel c'est à ce
moment là que le développement personnel
commence à avoir du sens pourquoi at on
besoin de sens bien parce que dans une
société de l'abondance dans une société
de l'opulence ou évidemment il ya des
inégalités évidemment qu'il y a des des
personnes qui ont des conditions de vie
infiniment plus difficiles que d'autres
mais d'une manière générale même les
gens assez pauvre même les gens
défavorisés arrive à survivre et malgré
ça eh bien ça peut ne pas suffire
on a malgré tout un besoin de sens on a
un besoin dit matériel on pourrait même
aller jusqu'à dire de transcendance qui
qui n'est pas simplement qui ne peut pas
être satisfait dans le confort matériel
de nos sociétés on a beau avoir le
dernier iphone on a beau avoir un
équipement un équipement matériel qui
fait que ben on a tout à disposition on
a notre abonnement netflix notre
abonnement internet
on a télévision on a une voiture tout ce
que vous voulez ça ne suffit pas à
combler le besoin de sens si existe en
tout être humain est le fait de nier
cette dimension cette dimension
immatérielle cette dimension
transcendante de l'être humain
je pense que c'est une erreur tout
simplement parce que ça fait partie
intégrante de nous et vouloir nous
l'enlever c'est simplement prendre le
risque que ce besoin s'exprime dans
autre chose
dans l'entretien que j'ai réalisé avec
marc et cas où on parlait du
développement personnel je lui disais et
je maintien que pour certaines personnes
le sens va être trouvée dans le
développement personnel et pour d'autres
il va être trouvée par exemple dans
l'engagement politique
pourquoi parce que la politique c'est
une manière de donner du sens à sa vie
en s'engageant en mettant sa personne au
service d'une cause supérieure donc
d'une cause transcendante et on pourra
on pourra dire tout ce qu'on voudra des
personnes qui s'engagent en politique
des militants quel que soit leur bord
quelles que soient leurs opinions
quelles que soient les valeurs au nom
desquels ils se battent ils se battent
toujours pour du sens
il se bat toujours pour un idéal idéal
d'une société juste
l'idéal d'une société dans laquelle tout
mon serai heureux n'importe quel
dictateur le plus infâme va toujours
agir au nom d'un certain idéal au nom
d'une certaine conception du bien et ça
c'est un comportement lié à la
transcendance liées au besoin de sens et
je maintiens là encore que c'est quelque
chose que nous avons tous en nous ce
besoin de sens et que l'on va l'exprimer
de différentes manières aujourd'hui dans
une société comme la nôtre une société
matériellement confortable une société
de l'abondance le sens ne sont plus aux
yeux lorsque on doit survivre et lutter
pour la survie
ça a du sens ça a forcément du sens et
on n'est pas soumis on n'est pas sujets
à la dépression et au questionnement
lorsque notre quotidien est une lutte
pour la survie
c'est à partir du moment où on a plus de
combats à mener
c'est à partir du moment où on n'a plus
rien à conquérir plus rien à obtenir que
l'on va essayer de trouver du sens dans
le développement personnel
voilà pourquoi avant de se moquer des
personnes qui s'intéressent au
développement personnel ou qui le
pratiquent
on ferait bien de se poser la question
de pourquoi est ce que ces personnes s'y
intéressent qu est ce qui les amène
qu'est ce qui les conduit
vers ce chemin et là on comprendra que
c'est avant tout le besoin de sens une
fois qu'on a dit ça qu'on a fait cette
petite analyse d'ordre on va dire
philosophico sociologique
je pense que c'est aussi intéressant de
s'intéresser au développement personnel
en tant que tel de ce qu'il peut
apporter à l'individu et de se demander
si c'est quelque chose qui relève de la
charlatanerie ou si c'est quelque chose
qui au contraire peut avoir des effets
bénéfiques
alors déjà de quel développement
personnel est ce qu'on parle comme je
vous l'aï dit il ya plusieurs mouvements
il ya plusieurs approches de ce
développement personnel et en fait on va
trouver absolument tout et n'importe
quoi on aura des formes de développement
personnel par exemple qui seront très
axé sur la spiritualité voir
l'ésotérisme le symbolisme le mysticisme
par exemple a donc une approche quasi
religieuse mais là je j'emploie le mot
religion sans aucune connotation
péjorative
mais on peut aussi avoir une approche
beaucoup plus pragmatique du
développement personnel qui va reposer
simplement sur des rituels des rituels
de vie des rituels d'action et il n'y a
pas d'opposition en fait entre ces deux
approches c'est simplement une question
de sensibilité parce que lorsqu'on
lorsqu'on approfondi le sujet on
s'aperçoit que les choses sont
totalement liés et pour ça je vais
prendre un exemple qui est un courant
philosophique que je vous invite à
découvrir qui s'appelle le pragmatisme
donc là on a le livre de william james
le pragmatisme et william james était un
psychologue américain psychologue et
philosophe est en fait il a il a
introduit cette notion de pragmatisme en
philosophie donc c'est un américain pour
dire que tout ce qui concerne la vie de
l'esprit se répercute fatalement dans la
vie concrète dans la matière et qu'il
n'y a pas de séparation en réalité entre
les deux sphères et que donc selon lui
ce qui est vrai sur le plan théorique
est aussi vrai sur le plan pratique et
inversement
c'est à dire que ce
qui fonctionne dans la pratique est
forcément vrai en théorie en france nous
fonctionnons sur l'idée d'une séparation
entre le domaine matériel du domaine
spirituel et d'ailleurs il n'ya qu'à
voir la réaction que peuvent avoir des
personnes dès que l'on commence à parler
de problématiques matériel dès qu'on
commence à parler d'eux une
problématique financière par exemple de
problématiques concrètes prosaïque tout
de suite ces personnes là vont être
scandalisés que l'on puisse entacher la
philosophie que l'on puisse entacher la
vie intellectuelle par des
considérations si basso civile que
l'argent que que le gain matériel que le
confort matériel que que les simples
objets voilà on m'a par exemple
l'entretien avec frédéric delavier était
très intéressante de ce point de vue là
des personnes ont reproché à frédéric
delavier alors qu'il était en train
d'expliquer comment la conscience a
émergé chez l'homme et comment cette
cette conscience amène chez l'homme
l'idée de dieu alors même qu'il était en
train de parler de ce sujet certains
étaient en train de commenter et de
l'insulté parce qu'ils portaient un
t-shirt avec son nom marqué dessus ou
parce qu'ils étaient en train de boire
une canette de monster donc à ce moment
là j'ai envie de dire qu'ils ont un
problème avec la dimension matérielle
est ce que ce sont les personnes qui qui
acceptent de vivre dans la matière ou
est ce que ce sont les personnes qui
s'offusquent que l'on puisse mêlée du
matériel au spirituel dans le spirituel
parce qu'après tout nous sommes tous des
êtres de chair nous sommes tous des
êtres incarner ne sommes pas des entités
flottante et eric qui qui serait turquie
serait intacte de toute corruption
matériel non nous sommes des êtres
corruptibles comme disait platon et la
partir de là nous devons assumer
endosser notre dimension matérielle
et le développement personnel assume en
réalité cette cette nature de l'homme
qui est à la fois spirituelle et
matérielle et ce développement personnel
va nous permettre de concilier les deux
c'est à dire de concilier nos
aspirations transcendante et spirituelle
avec notre vie pratique et ça c'est
quelque chose de fondamental parce que
ça rejoint selon moi la véritable
définition de l'activité philosophique
qui est de faire coïncider sa vie
pratique avec son idéal ses idéaux
spirituelle intellectuelle philosophique
ou moraux et d'ailleurs les philosophes
stoïciens pour parler d'eux dans
l'antiquité
il avait déjà d'une certaine manière
compris sens et leur approche peut nous
faire penser à un embryon du
développement personnel
alors évidemment je ne vais pas sur le
même plan la philosophie stoïcienne et
le développement personnel
je dis simplement que ça n'a pas ce
n'est pas absurde de faire un
rapprochement
ce n'est pas absurde de voir un lien et
de se dire que le développement
personnel s'est nourri de cette
philosophie de l'antiquité de cette
philosophie stoïcienne dans laquelle il
n'y avait pas de séparation entre le
corps et l'esprit
dans laquelle on envisage l être humain
dans sa globalité dans son intégralité
et dans laquelle dans ce courant
philosophique le stoïcisme au préconise
que l'homme agissent en conformité avec
sa vie philosophique avec ses idées avec
ses valeurs le développement personnel
c'est ce qui va permettre de concrétiser
ce que l'on a dans l'esprit et c'est là
où où on arrive à quelque chose que
certaines personnes ont parfois du mal à
comprendre c'est l'idée que la réalité
dépend en grande partie de la pensée qui
dirige notre action qu'est ce que ça
veut dire
ça veut dire que si on a une approche
purement déterministe du monde on va
dire chaque cause produit un effet nous
n'avons pas de liberté eh bien on se
condamne de facto à être passif dans
l'existence parce qu'après tout à quoi
bon entreprendre
à quoi bon prendre des initiatives à
quoi bon faire preuve d'audace puisque
de toute façon le résultat sera le même
le résultat est déjà prévu programmé à
l'avance et donc quoi qu'on fasse quoi
qu'on dise quoi qu'on veuille ça ne
changera rien voilà pourquoi le
déterminisme en philosophie
même si selon moi il est valide il est
valable sur le plan de l'explication des
phénomènes du monde et devient un
handicap il devient un frein dans
l'action le développement personnel va
consister à dire que nous ne sommes pas
les esclaves du déterminisme au sens où
on conserve un pouvoir d'influencé le
monde et d'agir sur nous mêmes le
développement personnel part du principe
que nous avons en nous un potentiel un
potentiel d'amélioration un potentiel de
transformation de soi qui peut nous
rendre heureux et c'est ça la finalité
première du développement personnel
c'est de nous rendre heureux et vous
voyez que le développement personnel de
ce point de vue là n'est rien d'autre
que un projet d'amélioration de la
société mais simplement qu'ils passent
d'abord par soit en s'améliorant soi
même on contribue à l'amélioration du
bien commun ont contribué à
l'amélioration de la société du
collectif donc indirectement du monde
voilà pourquoi le développement
personnel ne me semble pas pouvoir être
réduit à une vision égoïste du monde a
une vision autocentré du monde
certes c'est une vision individualiste
dans le sens où l'individu est est posée
comme étant premier en tout cas premier
dans dans l'ordre de du changement on se
change d'abord soi même
avant de vouloir changer le monde et
vous remarquerez que c'est peut-être
moins autocentré c'est peut-être
beaucoup moins narcissique que de
vouloir changer le monde sans se poser
la question de se changer soi même
après tout lorsqu'on veut changer le
monde sans se poser la question de ce
que l'on est ou de ce que l'on vaut le
sans se poser la question par exemple de
sa légitimité à vouloir changer le monde
qui est on pour vouloir changer le monde
et le rendre conforme à nos aspirations
personnelles après tout est ce que ce
n'est pas finalement ça une démarche
narcissique est ce que ce n'est pas
vouloir changer le monde sans se poser
la question de se changer soi même
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui me
semble important a rappelé le
développement personnel
c'est un ensemble d'outils qui nous fait
prendre conscience que si on lève un
certain nombre de barrières mentales un
certain nombre d'eux de blocages
psychologiques un certain nombre de
préjugés préjugés sociaux préjugés
moraux préjugeaient philosophique
puisque nous avons tous une ne
philosophie inconsciente au moins
inconsciente
si on enlève tout ça tout devient
possible alors quand je dis tout devient
possible évidemment si je me jette de
mon balcon en espérant m'envoler j'ai de
fortes chances de le regretter parce que
ça n'est pas possible
physiquement ça n'est pas possible par
contre si je décide d'interrompre mes
études de commerce de marketing pour
devenir astronaute pour devenir médecin
pour devenir avocat pour devenir tout ce
que vous voulez et bien en réalité rien
ne l'en empêche
rien ne s'y oppose dans la matière ça ne
contredit pas les lois physiques et à
partir du moment où ça ne contredit pas
les lois physiques c'est possible oui ça
peut contredire une certaine forme de
déterminisme social qui nous dit que il
faut être issu d'un certain milieu pour
accéder à certaines positions sociales
ça c'était là c'était là l'analyse de
bourdieu sur la reproduction
les fils d'ouvriers deviennent ouvriers
les fils de médecin devienne médecin
voilà plus ou moins un pour caricaturer
un petit peu la position de bourdieu
peut-être qu'à l'échelle collective
c'est exact ça se constater ça se
vérifie mais l'individu qui est en
questionnement sur lui-même l'individu
qui est en position de choisir son
avenir de définir des objectifs et de
les accomplir
s'il part de cette position déterministe
il est clair qu'il ne fera rien et il
est clair qu'il vivra toute sa vie avec
une frustration qui l'empêchera
d'atteindre ce bonheur imaginez un
sportif à qui on dirait par exemple de
toute façon si tu affrontes cet
adversaire il est certain que tu vas
perdre à ce moment là le sport lui-même
n'a plus de sens puisque le sport c'est
aussi le défi c'est le fait de chercher
toujours à repousser ses limites
c'est le fait de rechercher toujours à
s'améliorer à aller au delà de ses
capacités
donc le développement personnel c'est ce
que pratiquent le sportif c'est ce que
pratiquent le sportif qui se dit
intérieurement je vais le battre je vais
gagner et rien ne m'empêchera et donc le
sportif il est obligé de se mettre dans
un état mental et psychologique
particulier qui va lui permettre de
mobiliser des ressources pour atteindre
son objectif
c'est donc un auto conditionnement qui
fonctionne sur le principe de la
croyance
parce que la croyance c'est un moteur et
même si cette croyance est une illusion
au sens où la croyance
après tout elle ne correspond pas à la
réalité matérielle la croyance elle est
propre à notre pensée à notre
imagination
et bien cette croyance elle peut avoir
des vertus une croyance peut être utile
et c'est là qu'on rejoint le pragmatisme
de william james qui disait que tous tes
croyances etc appartement où étaient
tous tes croyances
il y à des croyances utile il y à des
croyances inutile
voire nuisible si vous avez une croyance
qui a des effets positifs dans votre vie
cette croyance devient vrai c'est ça la
position pragmatique pragmatiste c'est
ça l'idée en fait développé dans ce
courant alors là évidemment je vois tout
de suite j'entends arriver ce qu'ils
vont dire mais n'importe quoi mais
comment peut-on dire qu'une croyance est
vrai alors même qu'on sait que la
croyance ne repose sur aucun fondement
qu'elle n'ait pas vérifié par par la
pratique par les faits parlent par
l'observation mais ça c'est un schéma de
pensée qu'on n'est pas obligé de suivre
on peut choisir l'illusion de soi on
peut choisir la croyance dès lors que
cette croyance va être mobilisatrice et
d'ailleurs il ne s'agit pas forcément
d'une illusion si je dis par exemple que
je souhaite devenir astrophysiciens je
sais très bien que je ne le serai pas
demain mais je sais très bien que dès
demain je peux entamé les démarches pour
le devenir et ça est-ce que ça relève de
l'illusion de la croyance non ça relève
simplement d'un constat factuel
je peux entrer dans un processus d'étude
dans une démarche qui va me permettre
d'atteindre cet objectif
qu'est-ce qui me l'empêchent rien ne
l'en empêche c'est ça le développement
personnel
c'est prendre conscience que de par
notre éducation
de par notre vie en société nous avons
intériorisé un certain nombre de
croyances limitantes croyances auto
limitantes qui nous empêche en réalité
de nous battre pour atteindre nos
objectifs et ce faisant aux créer une
société de la passivité et donc une
société de la frustration dans laquelle
on va critiquer dénoncer jalouse et
parfois ceux qui atteignent leurs
objectifs
comme si le fait d'atteindre ces
objectifs étaient la preuve d'un
comportement suspect était la preuve
d'un comportement louche de comportement
pas forcément éthiques
ça cache quelque chose quand quelqu'un
réussit c'est ça qu'on se dit on à ce
réflexe intégré en nous de mettre de la
suspicion dès lors que quelqu'un a
réussi quelque chose que nous n'avons
pas réussi à faire le développement
personnel part du principe que au lieu
de critiquer au lieu de jalouser ou de
dénoncer on peut soi-même devenir acteur
et mettre en place les actions et les
moyens pour atteindre ses objectifs
ça ne veut pas dire qu'on va forcément y
arriver ça veut dire qu'il est certain
qu'on n'y arrivera pas sondé rien en
place pour y arriver
c'est ça le message principal du
développement personnel en tout cas
d'une certaine approche du développement
personnel parce que je voulais dit il y
a mille et une façons en réalité
d'entrer dans le développement personnel
donc vous voyez que ce qu'on appelle la
croyance en fait n'est pas forcément là
où on pense qu'elle est on dira que les
personnes qui pratiquent le
développement personnel sont soumises à
des croyances c'est ce qui fait
d'ailleurs que dès qu'on parle de
développement personnel tout de suite on
entend en arrière fond les mots de
d'escrocs charlatans dérives sectaires
gourou c'est à dire des mots qui vont
aller jouer sur la peur qui vont aller
jouer sur 7 sur ce cerveau sur ce
cerveau reptilien qui va nous mettre en
insécurité
au lieu de se demander tout simplement
mais qu'est ce qu'il y aurait à retirer
de bénéfique dans ses pratiques
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'autant de
personnes vont vers le développement
personnel si il n'y a pas quelque chose
à en retirer
et ça permettrait d'améliorer toutes ces
techniques plutôt que de simplement
considéré ce qui recourt comme des
pestiférés ou des personnes manipulable
influençable ou qui n'ont pas de cerveau
la croyance n'est pas forcément là où on
pense qu'elle est qu'est ce qui relève
de la croyance est ce que c'est le fait
de se dire qu'on est capables demain
d'entamer les démarches pour devenir
astrophysiciens pour devenir du front
pour devenir boulanger pour devenir tout
ce que vous voulez est ce que c'est ça
la croyance ou est ce que c'est le fait
de présupposer que deux
toute façon quoi qu'on fasse on n'y
arrivera pas et que ça ne sert à rien de
vouloir contredire les lois du
déterminisme social que ça ne sert à
rien de vouloir s'opposer au schéma au
conformisme de dire que c'est peine
perdue que c'est perdu d'avancé
est ce que ce n'est pas ça la croyance
est ce que la croyance ce n'est pas le
fait d'affirmer quelque chose sans avoir
aucune preuve et simplement de
considérer que l'individu est un
puissant que le poil de la société est
trop écrasant pour que l'individu ait
son mot à dire
c'est ça qui relève de la croyance parce
que ça relève d'une confusion absolument
totale entre les lois du déterminisme
social qui nous gouvernent
collectivement et notre rapport
individuel à nous-mêmes qui n'a
strictement rien à voir avec ces lois
le monde est fait de cas particuliers au
sens où chacun va vivre différemment et
individuellement son rapport au monde
d'une manière collective d'une manière
générale effectivement on respecte ce
schéma consciemment ou non en tout cas
le schéma déterministe il se vérifie à
une échelle collective c'est exact mais
vous qui êtes en train d'écouter
actuellement vous qui peut-être entendez
mes paroles et vous dites ça a du sens
pour moi ça fait écho à certaines choses
sur lesquelles je me suis déjà interrogé
vous qu'est ce qui vous empêche qu est
ce qui vous empêche de mettre en place
des choses pour améliorer votre vie
concrète matériel mais aussi spirituelle
votre connaissance de soi votre
connaissance du monde
j'ai fait énormément de vidéos pour vous
inciter par exemple à lire des
philosophes
je parlais tout à l'heure du stoïcisme
le stoïcisme est une philosophie du
développement personnel dans le sens où
c'est une philosophie extrêmement
concrètes qui va avoir des répercussions
dans votre rapport au monde dans votre
rapport aux autres
qui va vous apporter une forme de
sérénité par l'acceptation et pas à la
compréhension et qui va vous permettre
de bien faire la distinction entre le
possible et l'impossible il ya une
phrase un stoïcien qui s'appelle
epictète qui disait rien de ce qui est
possible à l'homme ne peut être au
dessus de tes moyens
une fois qu'on a compris ça on a compris
que la question du déterminisme et de la
liberté était un faux problème
c'est un problème purement intellectuel
c'est un problème qui n'a pas de réalité
matérielle dans le sens où si on a
compris ça rien ne va nous empêcher de
poursuivre et d'atteindre nos objectifs
donc la question que vous pose le
développement personnel c'est de savoir
qu'est ce que vous voulez et quels sont
les moyens que vous êtes prêt à mettre
en place pour y arriver pour atteindre
vos objectifs
et quand je parle d'objectif je parle
d'objectif au sens très général c'est ce
que vous aurez identifiez-vous comme
étant un objectif
peut-être que pour vous rencontrer des
gens dans un lieu dans un bar par
exemple au théâtre où n'importe et vous
adresser à des inconnus peut-être que
pour vous c'est déjà quelque chose
d'extraordinaire quelque chose que vous
n'envisagez pas peut-être que pour vous
ça représente un objectif que vous
souhaitez atteindre
qu'est ce qui vous en empêche
concrètement matériellement rien et vous
le savez donc le développement personnel
va peut-être vous vous donner des outils
pour vous mettre en confiance et pour
apprendre et comprendre qu'en fait vous
avez le pouvoir d' accomplir ce que vous
désirez c'est un objectif qui peut
paraître dérisoire pour certaines
personnes certains vont peut-être se
moquer de cet exemple parce que ils ne
comprennent pas que les objectifs sont
propres à chacun et que l'amélioration
de soi ça passe aussi par combattre tout
ce qui fait blocage en nous combattre
tout ce qui nous empêche d'être serein
combattre tout ce qui fait que on aura
toujours une boule au ventre
une appréhension une gêne à faire telle
ou telle chose alors qu'on sait très
bien qu'en réalité on pourrait le faire
tout simplement parce qu'on voit d'autre
le faire mais qu'on s'interdit de le
faire
le développement personnel est une
manière de lever ces interdictions et de
vous dire toi aussi tu peux toi aussi tu
as le droit donc toi aussi
vas-y fonce voir là il y aurait
énormément de choses à dire que je n'ai
pas abordé dans cette vidéo sur ce sujet
mais peut-être que je consacrerai une
prochaine vidéo pour revenir sur vos
questions par exemple si vous avez des
questions
les demandes de précisions vous pouvez
les laisser dans les commentaires
n'oubliez pas de me suivre sur les
réseaux sociaux ma page facebook mon
compte instagram et un grand merci du
fond du coeur à toutes les personnes qui
me soutiennent sur tipi on se dit à
bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo et
surtout soyez sages
[Musique]
oh